da jede zweite junge Person in der
Schwiz hat der Traum vom
eigeheimeim den
ichock unerschwilich nur letzte Jahr
sind immobiliieprise um knapp 30%
gestiegen wie viel kostet insgesamt rund
1,7 Millionen also Hypothek bin enorm
Hal wo man vielfach vergisst ich bin
selber auch immer Eigenheim aufgewachsen
und ich merke ich Wunsch auch aber warum
[Musik]
eigentlich ich er wie ich hat Erde
Wunsch nach eig im Gegensatz zu mir ist
für in der Traum aber schon
griefbarer aber n W Erik mit Mutter Z
ja ja
wohnzimmerzimmer im
s
lieblingszimmerst er hat mirenüber ein
großer vteil in Sache
eeimer handwerklich begabt
ja
Bett
abtis
Maschinerie
da in
leopardos
in eeim sauber gemacht saber gemacht sch
er
e und schon
vermtet warum hast du eigentlich der
Wunsch nach eig die
Heime es ist soam mit dem Umbau vom
burhus also burhus war so der Traum
und wie das da wie das
hier
Jaber mus
saber Kauf irgendwie
ja nicht der wsch wsch
nachber Bau B
jetzt
Werkst ja STZ wi
her jetzt gar nicht
abgeschreckt
[Musik]
vom Sturz sanit
fr V Beschäftigte Erik anders viel
größer Projekt und dem bin da der er h
nämlich das V
Großelter Berner W so sag bin nicht
traditionell so die Schwizer
Tradition jetzt gar nicht so mi
aberßvater sch vorher groß jetzt Mutter
auf
gewachsen groß
kindprach
ja es h über das ist schon mal ein
Vorteil wo aber längst nicht alle Hand
ich ma mich mal schlau und recherchiere
wie viel Eigenkapital brücht zum es
eigeneim kaufen darum kurzes paar zahle
l husinfo.ch muss man Hus im Wert von
ein Million mindestens 200000 Frank
Eigenkapital und es jahesommen von
174000 Frank das sind die meiste junge
nzur verfügig ich momentan auch nichter
ich würde in Zukunft mal Erbe Sowi t wo
auf der
baustff V eeim got gerade in
[Musik]
erfülligm Perf momentan wohnt T mit
ihrem und ihr Tochter no in
knossenschaftswohig im Kanton Z
2024uges ne da der Granze
zum istch TÜ
da dieang ja
daang
wir wie viel kostet insgesamt rund 1,7
Millionen ist schon eine große Summe ja
wir jetzt beide ervorbezug V beid
S und für alterke
immer und wir Bad
wtzechi da ist nach St da G da G
genau und dann gut man e da in
wohbereich mit der auf der Kuch und da
gibt noches
Zimmer mal überle das füris anders nutz
Geld nicht ehrlich gesagt ja ist
irgendwie
dass
wir bis fix oder
sag wir hab jetzt paar schö Reise letzte
Jahre
jetzt nur für ein das kan ich gut
navollziehen aber das braucht Platz und
nicht alle fre na
derpr Bau sind nicht was Traum v
eeim ich
denke aufachen bistind beide
aufwachsen W gehört ja also das
Standard wir ja ich Eheim aufgewachsen
was sicher Trum vom eig die Heim
stlärt V meine Elter fühlt sich
irgendwie immer n wie die von
mir FES oder f brandig W ich kan duf
zurück es fühlt sich anders mir W ich
jetzt drin wohne so als wär
mies mir ist durchus bewusst dass es
auch gute die grü geht wo g der Wunsch
vom eeim sprech z.B dass es hezutag
ökologisch und rumplanerisch wenig Sinn
macht in der Schwiz sind wir übrigens
Schlusslicht V Europa in Sache
Wohneigentum n ein Drittel von der
bevölkerb so und trotzdem Hälfte von der
Junge hat der Traum warum eigentlich das
W die von Felix her erfahre er ist
soziolog und beschäftigt sich mit der
bedü von
Wohneigentum also elich so es vi
selbstbestimmig also mit das eig
Territorium
verwirklich es Gott darum dass natürlich
die Unsicherheit größ worden
sind
sichbeitsle aber
und das sicher Faktor sie D dass man se
Arbeitsplatz groß rumbüro digitalisier
permanent
überwach tastchlag etc und das WE
natürlich
sehch ortber bestimmen und
mikropie so
zuchench genauide W so
ja ja wie wichtig es wohne ist was mir
der Felix her hand vom Magazin
zeigen Heft zum
BNE alles h
ja okay
danke sind das sind dem mittelgroßeios
sind
da das ideale Heim sind do e dr
dral sind sind sind e nurwen und da wden
natürlich ganz Klar Bilder vermittelt
und nor
vermittelt Herzstück harmonischche
fmklang der W alles kann wunschlos
glücklich
also es wird da
eigent wunderbare weltprache und selst
wo
finanze heißt diese Policen lassen ein
ruhig schlafen also es geht
dann büen war gestern der ST etc also
insgesamt Brave New
World
daster wie aus dem
Bilderbuch
interpretier wir das
klarind onomische Interesse und medialeü
W wirk
Set werden aber
es Botschaft W bel und der eigeimtraum
PUs Inter
hypothekauf aber gichitig
große Restriktionen werden
überhaupt sozial positioniert du
kom gellschaft mus dann haben natürlich
ganze Industrie eig wo Zelt über über 70
Heft Hus und Wonnen eigentlich
thematisiert und das Bild eigent das
Idealbild eigentlich da eigentlich
zeiget
den
werbg der stat großes Interesse hat das
eigentlich Wohneigentum Kauf und
Wohneigentum geht eigentlich
Wohneigentum der und das weiß mus
untersuchig
das mit quas politisch aktiv und und
politische politische sichbringen
also ist das eigentlich verstandlich
Interesse also das Gespräch l mich jetzt
doch sehr stark an Wunsch nach eig die
heim
zwifle we irgendwie ist es ja logisch
dass
lü zuu führt dass man sich das kann
wünschen aber zum jetzt noch so K dass
damit t hat we Werbig und we Bilder mit
konsumiert und das auch politiklus auf
das nimmt das L mich schon sehr stark D
zwifle so wie viel von dem Wunsch W ich
verspüre ich wirklich intrinsisch und
aus mir
und wie viel und
auf und jetzt frage ich mich schon ob
eehim auch sie aber wir merkt man dann
mit dem Traum vom eigeim auf dem holzwg
ist auf der Suche nach Antwort treff ich
Fabian sie hat Traum vom eig dieonppt
und wieder
Verwurf ich bin
in ganz normal und wir
auch ja Familie und Kind und
so Traum und ja bis man den Hus K und
dannn ich Bezirk den auseinand und ich
hab nach gemerkt oh wow S ist eigentlich
gar nicht me Traum sondern vor allem der
Traum von me Partner aber ich glaube ich
hab wie gemerkt eben Mengis ist einfach
auch nur die isch s man vergisst
wirklich die andere s dass man ganzes
husm
Putze und ja dass man auch viel schaffen
für da also pthek bin de enorm da halt
so wo man vielfach
vergisst ja ich glaube es ist ein sehr
hoch Anspruch wenn man denn mehrfach fer
will im J und der GTE und alles drum und
man kann sich dann wirklich Verl der
Hektik und gestresst und man macht viel
zu viel und ich glaube da hab ich wie MS
lern prioritäte setz was ist mir
wirklich wichtig und was ist nice to
Fabian darum ganz anders mal in weg mal
Z unterm mal auf Besuch ich ne schnell W
mit kan te
machen fein W m das jetzt h das ist von
der Kollegin genau wo ich hausitting
mach ganze lebe Kollegin genau sch
Schlüssel hab Finger sind bisschen
abgefroren
so wie lang bist den jetzt da da eine
halb Woche genau wie lang und jetzt noch
bis mentig genau und
ja so ist
wie KOF wichtigste drin der fabian ist n
wichtig eig die vi W sie liber flexibel
und got kompromissim wohne pas sich der
Bedürfnis von der husbesitzer und von
der
hauptmin andere
rum aber dass Du
vielleicht finanziell nicht so viel mus
investier
oder ja
also ich hab einfach wie gemerkt mir ist
im Moment oder einfach längerfistig mir
ist wichtiger dass
ich Welt ghen weder wie ich wohne und
will da einfach ja wichtiger ist m ich
auch wie bereit sie zum im
wohne downsiz
od ja Kompromiss und
zurück
ja
wor
minimalistisch le genau wie bereit sie
ich glaube einfach der Luxus kann man
sich vielleicht nicht unbedingt
langfristig aufrechhalte zum viel reise
und Lux wohne und alles
miteinand drum ich bin wie bereit zum W
reduzier dass ich ja auch ganz klar
finanziell also auch finanziell spare so
während Fabian der Wunsch nach eigene
die
los wer vorstelle anders z wohne
Block
nicht BR
einf Block oder
so
Natur im Garten
B das ist es groß über und Umbau mit
jüere
schwana sie w aber nicht n für sich
bauen sondern größere Plan hier so viel
Möglichkeit
schon vi Parteien sich und doch daspü
ich es g Profit das H ist
Herzensprojekt also ja da
Traktorfahren Großvater
Traktor Traktorfahren mit dem
ja
Trak hier
s
sich od sogar Absicht
schwimmen
familenfest mit also ja
grillmer so by zu der groß
inklusive
bis gemacht hat wie wenn wie wenn das
überhaupt könen
leisten also aktuell s be
studieren mit der Aussicht dass man der
ein so mit einem Bachelor niau veren
also das sich noch lit noch viel vor der
grundlag zu
bildde aber das hat
eigentlich Problem sie
jaum ma wenn
früh der Kredit bekt früher das
erforderliche Geld
auf
wo stmen aber wir ST eigentlich
Großelter zu den Zukunftsplan das war
beste war die beste
lö
warum meine Tochter üpringen sie hat
nicht das ver Interesse und der Sohn das
Interesse und
überspringen
über über je nach M
machen die
das der
Familie W sich Wunsch V Eheim immer wi
auflöst wir ziemlich sicher in erfü hier
das ist mit Trum vom eheimb
aber die
Freiheit ja sag jetzt mal jed
Tag
lassig also W jetzt im Alus V er und gr
hat sich mE Wunsch nach dem Eheim schon
letzt mal aufbäumt würde ich
sagen aber alles in allem nach der
Reportage merke ich dass der bei mir
mega aufgeweicht ist und nach dem
Gespräch mit dem Soziologen Felix K und
S mir noch mal bewusst wurde ist dass
der Wunsch nach Eheim mir VFT wird bin
schon sehr stark am hinterf und ich
glaub ich muss mich jetzt mit der
gedankinetzen was steckt Wunsch wirklich
dahinter und ist es wirklich eigeneim
oder muss ich mir einfach überlegen was
ist mir wichtig beim wohne und wie kann
ich das umsetzen so und jetzt wird mich
nur interessieren W ihr der Wunsch nach
eig die Heime schrib mir gerne Kommentar
und wenn euch das Thema interessiert
dann empfehle ich euch SRF do Serie zum
Thema Trum V Eheim wir hab sie euch da
verlinkt